咱们继续上课啊。
昨天呢丁光呢讲了一堆。
讲了啥呢？咱们简单回顾一下，我其实也讲的有点多了。
昨天讲了。
什么是编剧？
对吧。
编剧的意义。
讲故事的意义。
然后咱们当编剧需要做的一些准备工作。
也简单说了一下影视圈的现状。
昨天第一堂课吧，大概说的这些这些内容，为什么讲这些？其实啊我其实就是想。
鼓励大家学学编剧，相当于昨天基本上就是在劝学了，劝学了。今天咱就正式开始呃，真抓实干，好吧，搂点实惠的。
今天讲什么呢？一般来说，编剧课程最先开始会给你讲故事的要素和故事的结构。因为咱们昨天说了，编剧本质上其实是讲故事，对吧？你得先有故事才有剧本，等于是剧本。
是从。
故事中来的。
所以一般的教学就开始跟你讲故事的要素。
但是我发现一个问题啊。
往往是在这一步啊，很多人立刻就放弃了。
我跟他讲怎么样讲故事，然后再讲怎么样把故事变成剧本，很多人就一脸懵的状态。我知道他们在心里在想什么，因为我初学了，我为什么说咱们这个课是实战派，我自己学学编剧的时候，我在这一步卡了很久，我卡什么？
我没有故事呀。
对不对？老师，你说故事几要素，故事怎么讲？
我要有故事，我这故事又很精彩，怎么干成剧本这一步。
没有那么难。
从1到2没有那么难。
其实应该解决一个从0到1的问题，就是故事从哪来？
对吧这个问题。
那。
这个问题在所有的教程中都没有人讲。
都没有人愿意讲这个事情，因为他有点抽象，不太好讲，这个词就有点抽象。从灵感中来。
灵感。
一听就神神叨叨的一个词儿，对吧？当然我们可以把它换成呃换成一个比较比较比较现代化的词儿呃创意。
有没有好一些？
好一些是字面上好一些，但你还是没有嘛？没有创意，没有灵感，对吧？这个问题怎么解决呢？
就是我们今天的课程的内容，好吧，可以解决。别我我刚才一说故事要从灵感中来，很多人已经开始收拾东西了。妈的，昨天让我买键盘，让我买小本扔了，对吧？坑我吗？这不是撂下别着急，可以有好吧。
可以有，我们就说灵感啊灵感是个啥。
我们平常接触这种词儿的时候啊。
基本上把这个词儿等同于灵啊等同于心灵层面的一些东西。
或者等层于艺术家层面的东西，对吧？我们说哎，你看人家他是个音乐家。
啊，音乐家那他他作曲呀、演奏他需要什么？他需要灵感。我们说哎，你看他他是画家，大画家，一幅画一池15000，对吧？那他在那憋什么呢？我那憋灵感。
我都觉得灵感就是跟艺术家挂钩的。
咱们编剧不是艺术家吗？
不是艺术家吗？
咱们是剧作家。
咱们是创作者，是讲故事的人，咱们也是艺术家，也需要灵感。
但是灵感不是什么特别神秘的东西。
灵感也是可以通过训练。
可以把控。
可以运用的。
我昨天说过啊，灵感每个人都有，你不要说你没有灵感，你有你只是不会去运用。
我昨天布置的作业，大概做到家做了吧。
昨天那个作业还记得吧？
别没做啊。
写下一个你最真实的幻想，对不对？
你的幻想。
你给我写下来。
待会儿我会告诉你怎么用。
来。
我们接着说这个灵感。
灵感是什么东西啊？心灵层面的东西。所以我们讲故事啊。
一定是。
始于心。
止于心，你必须先。
有一个这样的。
想法或者叫冲动。然后呢。
成语脑。
成语呢。
怎么理解这个问题啊？
就是一个。
新的故事。
在诞生的时候。
他得先有灵感。
然后呢。
是个比较直觉的东西。
但是你要把它加工成故事，它是个理性过程，需要用了大脑。
所以我们就来讲。
这个问题这节课我们来攻克这个问题，好吧。
首先我们来说灵感的来源问题。
不解决这个问题，很多同学上来就掉队了，我也曾经在这里卡过，我跟你跟你们说了，对吧？解决灵感来源问题，灵感两个来源一来自于你本身。
也就是你的肉体。
来自于你的肉体。
肉体上有什么？我们的肉体上有什么？我跟你说。
哎，肉体上东西多了，肉体上东西多了，有欲望。
有欲望。
昨天我布置的作业。
我为什么让大家认真对待呢？昨天布置的作业。
就是欲望。
你的那些。
少钱。
或者是跟谁在一块儿。
或者是成为一个什么样的人。
假设我当年走对那几步，我现在会是怎样，对吧？
就是欲望。
欲望一部分是欲望，还有一些是幻想。
都是来自于你的。
来自于你的身体的。
这种东西。
不光是灵感最主要的来源。
往往也是一个故事最核心的东西。因为这个东西它最真实。
你说肉体里面还有什么？
还是什么？
恐惧。
恐惧也是发自肉体的。
恐惧也是很好的灵感来源。
我跟你说，在于你是你跟跟你欲望相对的啊，我们说我们经常。
除了。
想一想这些白日梦，想想这些好事以外。
你有没有想过那些不好的事情？
那些让你恐惧的事情。
一想到会打个冷战，哎，哎呀呀就你你连想都不去敢去想那种事情。
那就是你的恐惧。
他也是灵感。
从现在开始，你要面对他。
他从内心揪出来运用它。
始于心诚于脑。
好吧，这灵感的第一个来源。
灵感的第二个来源。
共情。
我昨天说过没有？
大家刻意的训练共情。
我会告诉你怎么去运用它。
灵感有很大的一部分来自于共情。
你自己的情绪用完了之后。
你就要开始观察别人的情绪。
别人的肉体。
他在幻想什么，他有什么欲望，他恐惧什么？
但这些不是你的，有时候就不那么真实。
那你怎么样来让他真实？
你跟他产生共情呀。
你中有他，他中有你。
产生共情。
也是灵感的一个来源。
当然这是第二阶段的事情。
第一阶段，我希望每一个人的第一个故事。
是发自于自己的。
所以我让你们写下自己的幻想。
就是我希望你的第一个故事是发自于内心的，发自于自己内心的，是自我的，是别人替代替代不了的。
你看啊。
很多作家或者是很多。
达沃尔的导演编剧。
都有个特点。
就是他的处女作往往是最好看的。
是吧为什么呢？
就说明他的第一个作品。
他的灵感是发自于肉体的。
发自于自己的肉体的那是最真实的。
然后就是最好的。
扑到及巅峰，说的就是这种，对吧？
但是那后面的东西为什么就差点意思了呢？就说明这个导演呀。
或者是这个编剧啊，还或者这个作家呀。
他是个天才型选手。
他。
天才有余，技能不足。
他把自己的肉体肉体用完了。
等到开始共情的时候，由于技术不足达不到。
这个共琴的技术，我们在后面的课程当中，我会不断的给大家训练。
但是第一个我当然是希望你写一个发自内心的对吧？你你目前来讲，在座大家在编剧上在创作上还都是处女嘛。第一次你你得卖个好，不是你得好好利用嘛，对吧？
这个我的已经没了，我现在已经天天在共情了，我的肉体已经枯竭了是吧？所以说这是灵感的呃两大来源。
好，那我们就针对这两个分开来说，一个是肉体的，一个是共情的。
肉体的欲望。
很多同学往往会问啊。
朱老师，我我的那个欲望啊。
恐怕南登大雅之堂。
我们写出来也不够精彩。
在这里我想给大家说一下。
关于精彩，我们至少要讲到第七节第八节课的时候才聊那个事儿，你不要去考虑精彩不精彩。
你想第一个一上来就能讲出精彩的故事，那咱这堂课就没有上的必要了。
一个课呃一个一个故事，一个剧本怎么变精彩，那是纯技术性的东西。
我现在教你的是基础性的东西，你先把灵感给我搞出来。
有些人说，那来老师，我的那个欲望。
我想要俩亿。
我想要有两个亿。
然后我就造我怎么花，你说这是故事吗？
这是故事吗？
不是。
他现在只就是就是一个灵感。
算不上故事。
更谈不上精彩。
那么我跟你说来，你肉体里还有什么？
还有恐惧。
你告诉我你的恐惧是什么？
可能是个事情。
可能是个情境。
可能是个人。
或者是某种人。
都可以让你恐惧。
我们还是说这个两亿梦啊，这个大俗梦。
这个梦应该比较共性，我也有，但我这个数字可能不是这个字儿，具体是多少呢？我就不跟你聊了，但我也有这个梦，我们就说这个两亿的梦，假设这个两亿的梦。
配上一个孔距。
我说我的恐惧啊。
我来自内心最恐惧的事情就是想起来就就想抹去不想回忆的事情。
就是我。
嗯。
就是我比较小的时候。
我偷过东西。
那有人说啊偷东西这么丢人的事，你能拿出来说呢？我跟你说。
不管是欲望还是恐惧，你内心的东西，你做一个编剧，你必须把它。
拉出来。
去面对他。
你连这个都没有办法面对，你就没办法搞创作。
所以我告诉大家。
我当时。
偷东西。
还有些人说，老师我也投过。
小时候偷爸妈的钱。
那不叫偷东西。
那个东西你能轻松的说出来，轻松的面对，那就不要偷东西。
我那时候因为穷确实是穷。
偷过身边人的东西。
就实在是太想拥有了，或者是。
一方面是呃穷想拥有，一方面也是觉得他们为什么他们有我没有，就出于嫉妒。
就偷个东西。
这件事情。
在我的成长过程中。
给我内心的折磨是非常大的。
我是不愿意面对的。
想起来之后，我就想啊好过去过去过去。
就他们还没有发生过，现在我已经不是那样。
但是他是我内心的恐惧。
内心的恐惧。
那我现在就告诉你。
两亿美好吗？
美好。
但是一个美好的事情。
他是不足以形成一个精彩的故事的。
那你就再给我来一个向下的力量。
什么事情？
把这个恐惧讲下来。
你现在。
有了两个亿。
对吧。
花着花着好开心啊，突然恐惧来了。
我的恐惧是什么？
后来。
你给我把这两件事情组合成一个故事。
你说啊呀，这是我这2亿不是偷来的呀，那谁能扣到2亿呢，对吧？
那你就想办法给我投到了2亿。
一个银行大劫案的故事说不定就出来了，对吧？银行里有2亿，你去银行里偷这2亿，然后。
能不能偷到，这不就是一个故事吗？它有上有下了有阻力了。
你说还有的同学说，老师，我这两亿我是自带的。
我没会不用去抢银行，我爸妈有钱，我爸妈给我的。
也可以嘛，来，你是一个富二代，继承了你爸的2亿。你呃你爸有2亿，给了你2亿。然后呢，有一天晚上你翻看翻看你妈的旧物，突然发现了你妈的秘密，你知道了你不是亲生的。
等于你这个身份。
是偷来的。
那么等于你这2亿也是投来的。
等于你。
马上就出现了一个身份危机，对吧？你想把这些信，你说你是烧掉，阻止你爸看到，对吧？还是说你要拿着这个去质问你妈问你妈，对吧？
你是从哪宝捡来的？对吧？当年你妈为什么把你换掉了？
是因为跟其他的你妈呃，你你爸年轻的时候，对吧？呃，有几个选择，你妈为了奉子成婚。
还是什么？
故事不就来了吗？
而且。
具备一定可看性的。
我们说检验一个故事啊我们说检验一个故事，它是不是已经成为故事了？
唯一的标准就是你把它讲给别人听一下，别人问哎，那后来呢？
如果他表现出兴趣，这个是这个故事。
就上路了。
如果你说哎呀，我老。
我老是做梦，我有两个亿。我跟你说，你旁边的朋友连问都不会再问一句。
对吧所以说那时候还不是故事。你如果说我老是做梦，我有两呃我呢我做梦我有两个亿，但是我这个两个亿是偷来的。旁边人哎，你哪偷的？
表现出兴趣了。所以说其实很简单。
灵感到故事，我当然后面会系统的说，但这是只是最简单的一个方式，就从你肉体里面找出一个欲望，一个恐惧，你往一起组合一下。
它就成为了一个最基本的一个呃冲突结构，好吧。
所以说这一集我给大家讲这个灵感啊。
我就是希望。
每一个人都能不断的从你的肉体中发掘潜力，或者不断的从生活中吸取营养。其实。
有很多人说，哎呀，我这个基础问题啊，我没有基础半路出家，或者是哎呀我也不知道我自己有没有灵感，是不是这块料。
你呀活了这么多年。
一直。
都有在做这方面的训练，只是你不知道。
就是说什么呢？
编剧这个工作啊。
你的基本功。
你说你去你去那个那个搞个运动，打打球。
你说先要先练基本功，你没有基本功就是不行。但是做编剧这个事情。
每个人都有基本功。
你的基本功是你你只要活着在喘气儿，你就一直在练。
只是你没有意识到你在给编剧打基础。
只是然后我们今天呢开启这堂课程，或者你开始想要对这个行业产生兴趣了之后，我教你把你以前打过的基本功基本功。
拿过来。
用起来整理出来，一是从从肉体的角度，二是从生活的角度。
把你。
的这些想象，这些素材。
都找出来。
然后。
第一步我们说我们说灵感变成故事的第一步就是把所有的相关灵感。
全部罗列出来，形成一个。
素材矩阵。
我们假设你就还是你搞你这个两个亿的项目啊。
有一你这两个亿的钱，你都是怎么花的，哪年得来的？
对吧然后呢呃那个阻力是什么？担心的事情是什么？
然后你。
你这个这个平常生活中共情里面，生活中看到谁真的有两个亿，他是怎么。
一样的生活，把你所有关于这件事情的素材。
搞一个矩阵。
它就会成为你的素材包。
怎么样把这些素材剧这里的素材包变成一个精彩的故事，怎么去抓取，怎么去提炼。咱们下一节课说下一节课呢就是故事的三要素。
下课。